en italie se faire pointer par un
pistolet peut être synonyme de sécurité
on contrôle la température de tous les
clients à leur arrivée si les lic
doivent se désinfecter les mains et
chaque client de remplir un formulaire
avec leurs noms et coordonnées pour être
contacter en cas de besoin
des mesures de prévention que les
italiens ont appris à appliquer
rigoureusement et qui font leurs preuves
après avoir subi de plein fouet la
première vague de l'épidémie
l'italie récolte aujourd'hui les fruits
de sa politique volontariste un
confinement mis en place plus rapidement
des mesures plus strictes et réactivable
à souhait un dispositif de traçage
efficace les raisons de ce petit miracle
italiens sont nombreuses
des précautions souvent similaires à
celles des pays voisins mais d'une bien
meilleure efficacité
le président de la république italienne
sergio matar et là il voit le sérieux de
ses compatriotes
ce que confirme cet infectiologue genou
en général ne sommes pas contents parce
qu'on dit toujours de faire encore plus
attention mais en réalité les citoyens
italiens étaient très respectueux de
toutes les règles du mauvais dans les
chaînes et quand je vois au journal
télévisé les images d'autres vies les
européennes
je vois beaucoup plus de gens son masque
qu'en italie une prise de conscience
collective qui a permis à l'italie
enregistré en moyenne seulement 37 cas
pour 100000 habitants
ces quinze derniers jours contre 235 en
france et 320 en espagne par ailleurs le
gouvernement s'est montré très prudent
lors du déconfinement et n'a pas hésité
à revenir sur ses décisions
lorsque les contaminations sont repartis
à la hausse mais ces dispositions
n'empêchent pas le corps médical de
rester très attentif
une plastie ces derniers jours je tirais
depuis une quinzaine de jours nous avons
assisté à une hausse des cas de
contamination et certains malades avec
symptômes ont dû être hospitalisés chez
nous et nous avons dû faire face à cette
nouvelle augmentation de personnes
contaminées
il fait une tendance qui reste à
relativiser l'italie comptait moins de
deux milles nouvelles contaminations
journalières quand l'espagne ou la
france en des pôles aurait plus de 10000
ces derniers jours